the world after being scarred by the
illness of a century
prepares to enter a new phase with a
recovering economy
where aspects of our lives are more
digital than ever
in these times there are few certainties
but one thing that's as close as
anything to certain
is that more and more organizations will
turn to business analytics and data
science
to make sense of the growing sea of data
in their worlds
and that's where i come in to help you
break into this wonderful world
so i've done a number of videos before
on things like learning data science
getting a data science job whether or
not it's possible to get a job without a
degree or not
all this fun but slightly disconnected
stuff
what i've not necessarily done is
connect all these different dots
so if you're somebody who's starting
completely fresh or you're in school
right now with the goal of getting into
data science eventually
how all this comes together to make you
somebody who can break into this field
well today i'm going to break down for
you how you can launch an exciting
journey into data science
in five different pieces before i do
that just a few usual asks
number one if you haven't subscribed to
my channel already please take a moment
to do so
then take another second to smash the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and then if you would like to chip in to
support my channel i'll have links in
the description of this video to my
paypal address
and crypto wallet addresses also please
note that i'm not a licensed or
professional career advisor or anything
of that sort
so please just take this video to give
you some hopefully useful food for
thought
as well as for entertainment purposes
all right the first piece of breaking
into data science that we need to talk
about
is your accreditation that is your
college degree
your certifications all that fun stuff
unfortunately it's not enough just to
have skills and to know your stuff
you need to have somebody else that can
certify the fact
that you have skills and know your stuff
that's essentially what a degree or a
certification is doing
now i've done a video all about whether
or not you can become
a data scientist without a college
degree
and the simple answer to that is it's
not going to necessarily be easy
but it is possible but the simple
reality of the situation
is that if you have a phd you're
probably in the best possible situation
if you just have a masters you're in the
next best position
followed by somebody who has just a
bachelor's followed by somebody who has
no degree at all
however there's absolutely no need to
have a phd
or a masters to break into the data
science field
and in fact it's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 50 percent of people
who don't have one of those advanced
degrees who are in the field
so for deciding what level of education
you want to get up
to honestly make it more of a personal
decision
ask yourself some key questions like are
you interested in doing research
would getting say a master's degree
actually help you learn more
and are you genuinely passionate about
the thing that you're pursuing for your
degree
what you don't want to do is commit
yourself to getting some kind of degree
especially if it's a master's or a phd
when it's in something that you're not
genuinely interested in
or worse yet you can't afford it's just
not worth it
so when i personally got my masters it
was in a circumstance where i was really
interested in learning more about
statistics
and i felt there was more that that
degree could offer me
ultimately i think that was the right
decision for me but that doesn't mean
that's the exact way that you need to go
but then if you don't have a degree or
you don't want to get a degree at all
don't worry there are options for you
too
namely those are coursera courses and
certifications
and i'll have links in the description
of this video to relevant things you
could do
as far as topics like statistics sql
r or python are concerned now the second
part of this
is that if you're going to break into
data science
you've got to know your stuff and i'm
making this very separate and distinct
from the piece about
accreditation and there's a couple
reasons for that
number one because college education and
courses
and certifications and things like that
mark the beginning of your journey of
learning
and not the ending and number two just
because you have a fancy degree which
says that you know your stuff
doesn't necessarily mean that you do
there's going to be employers out there
that have expectations for you to have
particular skills
and then oftentimes during the interview
process they're going to put the skills
that you claim to have
to the test so the natural follow-up
question is
what are the necessary skills to have in
order to break into data science
with the understanding of there's way
too many different things out there
and there's no way that a normal person
who's just getting started
trying to break into the field can know
absolutely everything
well i have a video on a study pathway
for data science where i break down
what skills i recommend learning in what
order
and why i recommend learning things in
that order but i'll try to break that
down at a high level for you here
i think of the domain and the business
side of things in data science
as the why then statistics is the what
and programming and computing is the how
and quite frankly if you don't have the
why or the what
the how isn't going to do you much good
it's for that reason
i recommend learning statistics first
and you want to learn things like
probability
distributions confidence intervals
hypothesis testing
and linear models because you need
different methods and approaches for
attacking various problems
statistics is also going to help you
appropriately interpret results and
findings which is going to help keep you
out of trouble
i say it in almost every video but
statistics
is what puts the science in data science
without it you just have data
pseudoscience after you have a solid
understanding of key statistical topics
and you've tried some practice problems
next you want to learn sql and you want
to understand multi-relational databases
that way when you encounter real world
data you can
query it and get it into a format that
you can very easily work with
after that you've got two juggernaut
programming languages in the data
science world to choose between
those are r or python pick one
and master it you should then have the
bare minimum requirements
in order to get a solid data science job
but remember
whether you just got your degree you
just got comfortable with a new
programming language for the first time
or even if you just landed your first
job the learning is only beginning
you eventually want to move on and learn
the other one of r
python you also want to learn linear
algebra and machine
learning and you want to know some
principles behind user experience and
human-centered design
again whatever you can learn from a
college degree
that's going to be the best approach but
there are tons of other resources out
there that you want to make use of
whether or not you're pursuing a degree
coursera classes
books and tutorials on websites like
w3schools or codeacademy
are all fantastic resources which will
cost you either nothing
or a fraction of the cost that formal
education is going to bring you
so just give yourself some structure by
making a plan
try to learn a little bit of data
science every day or as close to every
day as possible
you stick to that plan and you're gonna
do just fine
next you need to practice your skills
and put the things that you've been
learning to the test
this is yet another one of those cases
where there's multiple different things
that you can do
and all those things are going to help
but some of them
are going to be better than others i
think the best opportunity you can
possibly get
is in an internship where you're
practicing data science to solve real
business problems
and it's in a domain that's at least
mildly interesting to you
you'll kill two birds with one stone
because it's a type of job experience
that
typically doesn't strictly require
previous job experience
so it's just going to make it easier for
you to get your first real job
and you're going to learn a ton in the
process but suppose that's not an option
well if you're in school and you're
performing academic projects
that's probably the next best option and
i get it
everybody hates group projects i used to
be one of those people myself
but i must say when i reflect back on my
experiences in school
the instances where i learned the most
were the ones where i was writing code
to solve real problems inside of a
project
these always gave me a ton to talk about
in my early interviews
and they're the easiest things that you
can do early on
in order to build out a portfolio more
on that in the next step
but then the last best thing that you
can do which is still great
is kaggle challenges these will give you
tons of experience
looking at other people's code which is
a phenomenal thing to do in its own
right
but also creating your own code to solve
different types of problems
and it just shows amazing initiative
because i guarantee you
there's tons and tons of people out
there who want to break into data
science
but they want to take shortcuts about it
they don't lay the proper foundation
and they're not going to be the type of
people who go out of their way to do
projects on kaggle
that's a terrific segue into the fourth
step of this
which is building out a portfolio this
is probably the quickest and easiest
step on this whole list albeit something
that not everybody
yours truly included has always put as
much time and attention to
as it deserves you want to put
everything that you've worked on
into a good version controlled system
like github
that other people can access now a good
portfolio
is going to tell stories with everything
in there
you have the opportunity to tell the
background and the context of problems
what type of solution you came up with
the code and the implementation of that
solution
and then if possible the outcome and the
impact of what you did
this is so powerful and you're killing
so many birds with one stone
on one hand you're just building a
foundation and something that you can
share easily with each and every
prospective employer
you have the opportunity to demonstrate
to them that you're focused on the
domain
and the business problem and the context
at hand
and that you're not just a code monkey
but you're also demonstrating that
you're proficient at writing code too
because rather than just saying that you
know how to write code
you have something tangible that you can
point to and tell a story with
and that of course brings us to step
number five which is
you guessed it landing a job this is
definitely where i begin
rather than say trying to start your own
data-driven business when you're fresh
out of school
trust me you'll learn tons in your first
few years in industry that you want to
get under your belt
before you start trying to engage in
entrepreneurial pursuits
okay at this point you have some kind of
accreditation
you've got some skills that are valuable
in the marketplace with some practice
under your belt
and you have a portfolio honestly this
last part
shouldn't be all that hard i always
recommend
rather than applying to hundreds of jobs
apply to fewer jobs
put a lot of effort into each and every
single application
write good solid cover letters tail to
each company
explaining how you can uniquely provide
value to that company's problems
and do things like reach out directly to
the hiring manager for that position
be honest about the things you do and do
not know
and just focus on how you can help that
company and deliver value to them
rather than on things like how much
they're gonna pay you
and just tell stories to them this is
where things like portfolios are really
gonna come in handy
because if you can describe a previous
problem you've worked on
with appropriate context describe the
actual problem
the solution you came up with point to
where they can find the code and the
implementation of it
and then also describe what maybe the
outcome or the impact was
i guarantee you you're going to do
better than 90 percent of the people out
there
competing for the same job if you can do
all of these things then you're off to
the races
of course after you get that job the
real fun only begins
data science is a journey involving
endless learning
some almost guaranteed nice money some
surprises and humility along the way
and one or a thousand late nights up
writing code but something that i just
think is really exciting about it
is that because it's such a brand new
field
many of us don't exactly know where
we're eventually going to end up
and i don't know about you guys but i
kind of prefer it that way
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please consider
sharing it hit the like button down
below if you haven't already
and leave me a comment down below and
just let me know how you broke into data
science
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data